this is the horse stance from kung fu or wushu
it's an excellent way to strengthen your
lower body
I practiced for over 10 years
I've got a little
bit of experience with this movement now
I see a lot of people on social media
teaching this movement
which is great
the intention is really good
but the technique is not there
and it's really important
to understand how to do this properly
you want to stand double shoulder width apart
so a really good way to do that
is to measure out your stance
like what I did
just there
the knees should be pushed out
so they're over the feet
with your feet facing forward
from side on
you should see that
the knees don't really go too far
past the toes
the hips are tucked under the body
shoulders above the hips
with your back nice and straight
at first you're going to struggle
to be able to even sit this high
for any good time
try to hold for 5min
and as you get better
you'll sink deeper into the position